so you can look at this from so many
different points of entry let's take an
obvious one right if a doctor went to
sleep 50 years ago and woke up today
nobody would allow that doctor in a
hospital to do surgery right but if a
teacher went to sleep 50 years ago and
woke up today and she or a good teacher
people be excited to have her in the
classroom education is a kind of area
that really lacks innovation lacks
entrepreneurship lacks dynamic thinking
it's very homogenous the debates are so
arid how long are we going to have the
same debates about you know you got to
find the perfect curriculum you've got
to be able to have this class size
versus that class size you need to
invest more in this or a little less in
that those are important debates don't
get me wrong but those debates are
absolutely inconclusive and aren't going
to get to the issues that I've been
hoping to be able to effectively
communicate here which is that if you
reward mediocrity if you pay people
whether they do a great job or they do a
poor job if longevity of service is the
most important factor in divvying up the
benefits in the system then the system
will work you you don't know systems
that work and which are built on
meritocracy in which excellence isn't
really the thing that people are
searching for and which excellence is
rewarded in which the toughest
assignments are oftentimes the
assignments you want your most talented
people to go to all of those things are
misaligned in public education and
they've been for a long time in large
measure public education is built on a
civil civil service trade union
industrial model and we need to move it
to a professional model in which
excellence is rewarded and competence is
properly dealt with the toughest jobs
attract highly talented people so that
our poorest kids get a fair shot at a
great education and those kind of
phenomena have to be addressed and
adjust meaningfully they're very painful
to address because they will require a
rethinking of the way we deliver
educational services in the United
States but a lesson until we get serious
about that I don't think we're going to
really see the kind of shifts that we
want to see you know it's 54 years after
Brown versus Board when the supreme
court not only outlawed segregation but
promised every kid in America an equal
educational opportunity it's 25 years
after nation at risk in which all the
problems we're talking about today were
identified and yet today in America
education is not equitably distributed
where you grow up what your family
background is affects the quality of the
education you get and that's in large
measure because we haven't really come
to grips with the issue of the equitable
distribution of a dull talent in the
system and until we get to dress that
things that we're doing here in New York
that are dressing that until we address
that we're going to continue to have the
same kind of in my view arid discussion
about yesterday's policies and
yesterday's programs the great question
and I'm not sure anybody has the perfect
formula but let me say first of all you
need to bring in far more
entrepreneurial innovative people wonder
thing wendy kopp and Teach for America
has done and done well they brought an
entrepreneurial group of people into the
educational equation so you've got
people who are running things like Kip
which is one of our great charter groups
running things like the new teacher
project that's so forth and so on these
are groups that are bringing big and
different ideas and any field that
thrives is a field that has an
innovative engine and public education
quite frankly doesn't it is a very
homogenous field so one of the things
we've done in New York is we've got some
incredible educators my deputy for
teaching and learning martial Isles my
deputy who runs the empowerment zone
Eric Nadel CERN he's a career educators
between the two of them and i probably
have 70-plus years in a New York City
public school system why the same token
I brought in some incredible people from
the Harvard Business School some people
from the legal profession my chief
accountability officer was just a lawyer
for the end up
CP Legal Defense Fund and then a law
professor at Columbia and what are the
great minds in America today if you mix
those people what you get is a
combination of institutional knowledge
educational expertise but much more
innovation managerial talent managerial
skills if you don't manage a service
delivery system like education a 20
billion dollar one in New York if you
don't manage it well it's not going to
get good results and good outcomes so
the mix has got to be thought of from
both halves of the equation in the end
education is a government service and
the government has got to be responsible
it kind of outsourced it it cannot
decide that third parties will do it
although you can bring in third parties
as we've done in New York City you can
bring in competitive principles you can
bring in accountability and you can
bring in innovation all of those things
are critical to the transformation but
in the end the government has got to be
accountable and that's why marrow
control if you think about it so weird
we've had school boards basically
running education and they've been
guided by the politics of paralysis and
if you read Mac Miller who I'm sure one
of the one of the real powerful thinkers
in this area he's got a piece in the
Atlantic magazine in January and what
she says first thing we do is kill all
the school boards because what you need
is the leadership of a mayor in a city
and the mayor is the single most
important government official in the
city and you want the mayor out there
responsible accountable aligning the
budget with the mission and standing
before the city and saying education is
our number one priority so that to me is
the right governmental structure and
then the group of people you want to
bring in to do the work it's got to be a
group of people that has the mix of
talents and if you choose them off on
one side if you have all managerial
types with no educational expertise that
won't work by the same token if you have
all educators with no managerial
expertise who don't get innovation don't
get differentiation in talent don't get
the use of incentives to reward
excellence and to make sure that in
competences tell
that those things are in a part of the
equation you'll continue to get the
results we're now getting 54 years after
Brown